thing where it's like a guy that is
gonna wait for a girl that's slept with
other men for marriage like he's kind of
a simp and that's why guys are leaving
the church because they thought they
were going to get virgins and they get
girls that have slept with multiple men
the women are gonna be awesome
you know what right A lot of people say
the women right but a lot of men go to
church
no you're right you're right but
the women they just leave them no so you
know but it's hard it's hard because
like I agree with you like I don't I
don't think people should sleep around
right like I'm with you but like at the
same time it's like I think a lot of
times the church leaves women single and
you see that because I walk into any
churches 70 to 80 women they're usually
single and and the thing is I meet a lot
of girls that are celibate you know and
so guys it just sounds like nonsense
it's like where what where was the
celibacy when you were your [ __ ] Chad
or Tyrone or whoever it was
I understand for you it seems a little
more like I think the younger girls are
a little bit more genuine because
they're they're younger when they do but
a lot of girls get there at like 29 to
30 with a kid and they're like yeah I'm
gonna wait again and the guys are like
[ __ ] that yeah that makes no sense but
and then this might be at a smaller
scale but it's like like a lot of times
I I do think the church leaves women
single because they tell them to be
celibate again but it's a bad deal for
men because they have to wait for a girl
to be like to get her to be married but
at the same time she gets all the
commitments I don't believe that go
ahead no no she's right she's right
still no she's not because nobody forces
the women to go to sleep no no no no no
no no no they go to church as a
backslider Auntie Jenny they go to
church Auntie Jenny let me ask you Jenny
speak then they go to church right the
women go to church thinking that they
can hide in the church and they can't
hide in the church they're only fooling
themselves because all they do some of
their women is go there to give their
[ __ ] a rest you understand
so when they're saying about Born Again
Christians it's not it's not now born
again virgin they just go there to take
the heat off their families and that's
what they go to give their family a rest
and you got you still want to say Auntie
Jenny you still want to say no because
some of them right I'm not gonna say
that somebody don't go to church but at
the end of the day they will go out
there and sleep with a whole heap of man
and then go when their fan is too hot
and then go and say you know what I'm
gonna chill out in church and wait for a
man to come and that's what it is a
church is not a resting place for a hot
Fanny do you know what I mean that is
not what it's there for if you decide
and I honestly because I'm religious if
you decide that you had enough and you
want to go there but don't go when it
when people go to church right after
having a relationship they think they
can go there and be born again no
they're not born again because you
really born again ain't no Boone again
you still have to remember all the men
that you've had and you start to deal
with all the men that you've had and you
still have to be honest with the men
that you're gonna have or the future
husband so don't go to church and think
that you can hide away all the heads
that you've had and all the men that you
fight because you can't hide it you're
fooling yourself but even even if the
girls are honest in the church yeah they
go to the man and they say hey um this
is what I'm selling I'm a used Honda
Civic here this is I'm selling myself a
new BMW prices and the men are like oh
uh why would why would I do that when I
could get another used Honda Civic you
know well the men need to go and get the
other Honda Civic because what the women
fail to realize is that there's a name
for women like that in church is it
monarch and there's women in there's
what they feel to realize is that when
all these women run to church right to
get away from it they don't realize that
there's some women in the Bible that
never have a man that always been in
church that will never ever ever have a
man and 90 of them women are gonna it's
like a religious leftover woman right
right you know I mean that's what
they're going to end up I know but
that's what I'm saying like a lot of
times when the church will encourage
women to wait till they're married after
they've had they're not virgins anymore
I think it leads to worse outcomes okay
because find a new church because
because again it's everywhere Auntie I'm
telling you I've had these conversations
people in Christian churches Catholic
Church like it's across the board walk
into any church in the west it's 70 to
80 women and and this is why because
from a reproductive like mating strategy
it gives all the benefits to women and
and all of the responsibility on the men
I go to church and I'm not hypocrite I
go to church regular and I'm taking
nothing I'm taking nothing because I
know as soon as I come out of church I'm
going to have sex
Auntie Jenner you gotta realize yeah
woman's go to church here as what you
said to go rest their Mindy yeah but
what it's it's like when you release it
I'm gonna use your example it's like
when you lose a family member you turn
to religion for comfort in it these
women go turn to the pastor for comfort
and the pastor start talking and
brainwashing them to me church is a big
brain or [ __ ] I don't need to go to
church to praise my God in it exactly so
they're getting brainwashing church I
know you said leftover that's why she
just said leftover oh wait no someone's
gonna come and get you man don't want
you you're a young Bentley from
the thing is right is that I find that
when the women want to go and find the
man right they will go all around the
world right they will go on holiday they
would look here and they would look
there and then when it comes to finding
a man in church they stick to the one
church now imagine
she said I go to a church and I don't
like it but I'm gonna why the hell are
you going to the church that you don't
like there's obviously no meaning that
you like the whole world is your oyster
I'm sure that when you're out there
looking man you look at them and the
whole world so if you want to find a man
in it you've got the whole world of
church she's like go to a Jamaican
Church you're going to find a man that's
because
why are you gonna stay in one church
when that church might not be right for
you are you saying there's multiple
strip clubs
go to all of them and test it out
I think they go to church or whatever
religious practice it is with the right
intention yeah they go there because
whatever they've been doing outside
hasn't been working yet and they want to
get closer to God even in within a
relationship marriage they want to do it
the right way yeah like the religious
way whatever that boom but I feel like
with women here with that kind of
comfortability now and familiarity with
the men what you're now constantly
around in church these men are still
still you know active there you go and I
feel like the familiarity now that
they've now built with these men and
this comfort and the safety they feel
around the Christian Brothers if it's a
Christian Church what happens now is
after a while you slip into the same
cycle but now it's just within a church
Community because not just within the
church you build like you join the group
chat now you're going out socially with
you know I mean different churches
different guys and now with that
familiarity it becomes easier for
in the streets you'll end up getting run
to you in church within the church and
when I say run to you it don't have to
be nothing mad like 20 man it could be
three or four yeah but but that 304 is
detrimental because it's within the same
community so now what you're doing is
your proper limit in your charts of
getting it that's why what Paul said in
the end the percentage is very high
which don't end up with the ring because
within your church Community you know
Marlon Aaron and John has run through it
so you're thinking like no that's mad
and you gotta go Church work with the
wife you know what Marlon Jonas
like the point the point is like I don't
think telling women to wait after
they've had sex produces good outcomes
and I see this because I see there's so
many celibate girls in the church and
the ones I believe that like actually
are celibate it's like they're still
single and they're so simple because
again they're selling a used Honda Civic
for new prices how come we're not
talking about the men you see my best
friends right because because the
problem is men and women are different
and women don't care if a guy slept with
a lot of people but we just okay like
this is kind of a need to be right and I
think on an innate level you know that
it's true because we just talked to the
girls on the couch just in this
conversation the men said by and large
they tended to want virgins where we
tended to want men that have slept with
other women and it's just true and it's
not it's not fun like it's not a fun
part of being a woman but it just it is
what it is like the women have
consequences for that stuff men get more
chicks who's lining up to for Drake and
saying oh did he sleep with too many
girls no ingenuously Britney Runner
they're running from in general it's
like a trophy for like a woman to have
to have that man for a woman to get wife
by a man that the majority of women want
it's like a trophy like he chose me
um in the majority like you you wanted
the popular kid that majority of the
girl is popular because majority
I mean
every day
father son get some counseling for your
funny trauma funny trauma oh you're
funny because that's why they have all
this funny trauma and then they go to
church trying to relieve it Jeremy
because I gotta speak because I got a
friend and she's been in the church for
like I don't know about 30 years and she
ain't got no man and you know what she
never went to church looking for no man
so she don't expect to go because she
never went to church with funny trauma
do you know what I mean so she always
went to church she said if a man that
was a man if a man comes along fine I
never it's a eunuch that's the word and
if a man doesn't come along I said to
her you're a unit he goes why are you
putting it on that me I've still got
time to find the man I said this one
give up mine now yo eunuch do you know
what I mean some women go to church and
they're going to church thinking that
yeah all women are supposed to find men
in church no some of the women are
supposed to be single in church for 30
40 years unless you do your research so
when you go to don't go to church trying
to get cancer for yourself
but they say to be fruitful and multiply
you don't you don't think it's going a
little bit against God to not go with a
man if you over if you're over 30 years
old who wants a great football for no
bag it seemed like having a liftoff
you know you just said you Nokia that's
used for a term that older woman that I
was never kidding it and she can't have
a kid no more so she it's like it's like
the term they use when a woman hit the
menopause
yeah
you know I thought that was um someone
that didn't have a dick no yeah
you understand what I'm saying though
right yeah so it's like it's like you
should be able to go to church they
should be able to go to church and free
it up
no I'm saying I'm saying a lot of times
I think the church leaves women single
because they encourage them to wait till
they're married after they've had sex
and what and what kind of guy is going
to do that when he knows you banged the
three dudes down the street
right because I don't see no one
dragging the women into church
I don't see no one so the church don't
turn around and say to women oh come
here we're gonna find the man for you
it's the women with their funny trauma
that decide to go to church so the
church don't make them stay there if
they will get cancer for the fanny
trauma half of them women if they got
cancer before they were interjected but
yet they're still screwing around
because they get canceling about the one
guy that broke their heart and then they
will move on they wouldn't be in church
so I don't I won't say blame the church
because at the end of the day nobody
gets forces into church they go there
their own free will they go there
because they figure themselves oh all
these men outside are treating me bad
I'm gonna come in here and find some
stupid Christian guy that's gonna take
me as I am because you don't care about
body care you know what those are the
eunuchs of the future those are the
leftover women
and I agree with you I'm just saying
like like this stuff to men it kind of
reports and this is just feedback I've
gotten because I kind of had the same
view as you before I just started
listening to guys talk more and it's
like from the men's point of view it's
like you're encouraging these girls to
wait again but what do we get out of it
we don't get a virgin bride why would we
do that and so and so stuff like that
makes men want to not go to church I use
a church leader you want to ask in men
how many how many of them guys go into
church and [ __ ] the girls and come back
out without everything a little man go
to church
right
now
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible